[Musique]
quand
d'abord j'ai voulu survolé le centre
ville de port au prince
vu d'en haut c'est moins dur la
souffrance n'a pas de visage c'est un
chaos de pierre un tricot de tentes
dans un hélicoptère de la minustah la
mission des nations unies en haïti nigel
fisher le numéro deux de la mission joue
le guide les chargés de superviser
l'aide humanitaire
[Musique]
ça dépend vraiment de la direction des
failles et des soufflets on peut avoir
du colis détruit la prochaine bien que
ce brillant
ainsi on estime être évalués à 250 mille
maisons et bâtiments sont détruits
vingt cinq morts ont endommagé ainsi que
le mtg n'y avait pas mal de monde même
si la maison semble être bon il préfère
rester dans les temps parce qu'ils ont
peur peut-être d'autres tremblements et
que la fatigue ce temps je sors des
kosovars
les couleurs bleues blanches pour les
teintes grises pour les immeubles a fait
c'est la palette du malheur a port au
prince la moitié de la population vit là
l'urgence fait loi 1300 quand dans tout
le pays
autant d'abri pour ceux qui ont survécu
un million trois cent mille personnes
sont aujourd'hui sans abri en haïti et
depuis neuf mois rien n'a changé ou si
peu qu'il faudrait un microscope pour
détecter un mouvement à mieux un petit
mieux sa maison même en bonnes
conditions doivent être détruite pour
permettre de nous de nouveaux rue des
canaux parce qu'il ya plusieurs zones où
il n'y avait pas de planification ainsi
même s'il pleuvait il y avait des
inondations mais maintenant ça va au
delà d'une reconstruction c'est pas
recommencer refondation aux fondations
c'était la différence c'est la
transformation
on veut pas reconstruire ce qui existait
avant le tremblement de terre à 7 est
absolument inadéquates pour la
population si on avait 85 % de la
population qui vivait dans la pauvreté
ce n'est plus le temps de l'urgence
l'onu et les ong ont fait leur boulot
sauveur de vie aujourd'hui il s'agit de
faire que toutes ces vies arraché au
béton à l'acier trouve tout simplement
l'envié de croire en la force de l'homme
port au prince n'est qu'à une quinzaine
de kilomètres de l'épicentre du séisme
dans la capitale haïtienne l'une des
équipes du monde en marche et rentrer
dans le camp de christ-roi le mal nommé
oui le christ où est le roi les bicoques
fait de tôles et de bâches sont bien là
et 2500 âmes s'accommode avec la dureté
de leur vie ici bas
tous les regards ne sont pas tristes
haïti la misère ne date pas d'hier
il n'y a pas ici de cellule
psychologique
chacun dans son coin digère le
traumatisme gédéon calixte pitt ici avec
son mari sa mère et sa grand mère
[Musique]
avant le séisme elle avait une grande
maison avec trois chambres
[Musique]
ouais moi je suis là je suis là avec
mike doit dormir par terre
oui la can à 60 2 1 sous le toit en tôle
la température dépasse souvent les 40
degrés et quand il pleut c'est encore
pire quand il ya la plaie en laisse deux
bouts de bois co sd c'est un temps
passera les allées l'eau tombe en bas il
passe en bas et il tombe
allez on laisse comme ça on attend l'a
pris parce que c'est pas une vie ça va
arriver ça
[Musique]
ici comme ailleurs l'état haïtien a été
totalement dépassés par les événements
dans les camps comme celui de crise
trois seuls des ong sont venus apporter
ponctuellement un peu dead un réservoir
d'eau potable 14 douche et 16 latrines
pour 2500 personnes
la promiscuité l'hygiène aléatoire la
maladie qui rôde partout comme si elles
étaient aux aguets pour saler un peu
plus l'addition un dispensaire a été
improvisée au milieu du camp avancé
les gens qui ont déjà des cartes avancer
là
avant le séisme gédéon calix était
infirmière dans une clinique privée
aujourd'hui sans emploi parce que sa
clinique s'est transformé en
millefeuille de béton elle travaille ici
bénévolement pour qu'on n'était pas venu
contrôler et attention
j'étais malade
l'incroyable chance d'haïti aujourd'hui
dans sa dégringolade
c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu à ce jour
d'épidémie ou de cyclone d'ailleurs si
cela avait été le cas toute l'armada de
l'urgence ce serait à nouveau redéployer
le problème majeur c'est le manque de
médicaments
j'avais la télé north america et à
maxime
hérésie le team barazi lui de revenir
lundi matin bayou bagnon mais samedi
vous de la chaîne hbo pour céline et
cesser la personne n'a pas tout fait
sauf un patient sur deux repart sans
médicaments nathalie mode et
l'infirmière responsable de la pharmacie
offre ce qu'elle peut et sait peu sans
que nous n'avons pas de rien du tout
le stocker m totalement épuisé le centre
espère recevoir de nouveaux médicaments
la semaine prochaine au milieu des
tentes
les plaques de béton déchiré sont
devenus des lieux de rencontre entre
potes
les soupes populaires ont été suspendues
depuis mai certains ici ne mangent qu'un
jour sur deux les haïtiens sont des
travailleurs
ici pas ou si peu de mendiants ils
disent donnez-nous juste un coup de main
pour ne pas décrocher pour que l'on
repart cette famille de neuf personnes
s'est mise au crochet confectionne des
bonnets pour un commerçant haïtiens qui
râlent et revendre en république
dominicaine largarde sont mal faites
une maille à l'envers une maille à
l'endroit 50 euros par mois un privilège
[Musique]
c'est ce qui nous fait vivre ça nous
permet d'habiller de manger de nous
déplacer
lui c'est le père il se prénomme du nord
il a été chauffeur de taxi collectif
mais les routes sont défoncées et qui en
plus rares et il n'a plus de boulot en
tant que citoyen je trouve que notre vie
est vraiment médiocre
on n'est pas habitué à vivre comme ça
avant dans mon quartier je connaissais
tous mes voisins ici mon voisin il jette
ses ordures devant ma porte je lui
demande de ne pas le faire mais s'en
fout et on se dispute sans arrêt pour
ses enfants aussi comme djenane 23 ans
difficile de s'habituer à cette nouvelle
vie on a une maison de deux pièces avec
une galerie on avait deux des meubles
dans tout ça démoli au dessus
cette année pas comme celui là est-ce
que vous avez l'impression qu'on est un
peu abandonné les réfugiés qui ont perdu
leur maison
bon pour moi on nous a abandonnés sachez
que depuis après le séisme dont l'un des
semaines de 22 janvier vous avez au mois
de février n'a trouvé de l'aide tom
enders s'est rangé à ce que le
gouvenement semblerait-il qui nous a
oubliés
je connais des jeunes on a des avenirs
jeu pour moi j'ai déjà à venir même si
que le temps m'amène ici je réfléchis
toujours je sais écrire je sais parler d
avenir formidable djenane qui ne sait
pas vers où elle va mais elle trouvera
parce que c'est d'abord une belle
personne parce que j'aime la beauté
j'aime la beauté mais je
c'est pas facile mais il faut il faut
quand même prendre soin de vous mais
c'est un peu de jus de pomme jolie comme
ça
des ateliers de danse pour se dire que
l'on a toujours encore de la joie aussi
dans le coeur personnes en haïti n'a
perdu c'était un sel dans les yeux qui
affiche sans vie de la vie
[Musique]
ans
cette dignité des haïtiens face aux
difficultés et à l'ampleur du désastre
m'a épaté elle permet de remettre à leur
véritable place quelques unes de nos
préoccupations d'européens jean marie
théodat est à lui seul un bon exemple du
courage des haïtiens universitaire
professeur de géographie à la sorbonne
il a vécu longtemps à paris après le
tremblement de terre du 12 janvier il a
décidé de rentrer à port au prince pour
reconstruire sa maison et son pays de
niveaux rez-de-chaussée et le premier
étage et qui s'est écroulé le 12 janvier
juste après que vous voyez de travers
juste elle a survécu miraculeusement
et quand vous vous décidez de devenir
vite vite votre mère vous installez donc
dans la propriété dans le jardin j'étais
venu de paris avec avec une tente avec
une sente que rêvent donc déployer que
j'ai installé et qui me sert à la fois
aujourd'hui de deux maisons dont claude
abri pour la nuit et le bureau et demi
voilà jean marie théodat devant la table
à laquelle il tient beaucoup parce
qu'elle fut la table de culture de sa
mère dit simplement l'essentiel
il ya une différence entre les gens et
les élites et ce pays ce sont d'abord
les gens qui l'ont fait mais ce que je
vois ce que j'ai pu observer c'est
l'extraordinaire courage des gens petit
peuple qui
avec enfants parfois leurs ongles de
moulis ce qui reste des décombres pour
faire place nette et on construire
rebâtir et puis il ya maintenant ce que
vous appelez les élites ceux qui
décident qu'ils sont face un tel
chantier
face à de tels défis que effectivement
on a l'impression parfois que le
décision tarde tard devenir des sas et
je pense d'abord une conséquence de
l'immensité du chantier
on est face à un triple défi un défi
social fort loger correctement
proprement d'aidé agréé sur un défi
économique cela un coup il faut trouver
l'argent est un défi je dirais pratique
qui relève de l'ingénierie
où trouver les engins ont trouvé des
ingénieurs ont trouvé les cerveaux aux
pensées l'état est dépassé par l'ampleur
de la tâche les organisations
internationales tentent de remettre
haïti sur les rails grâce aux 10
milliards de dollars de dons sur cinq
ans mais comment faire sans
planification camp corail dans la
banlieue lointaine et aride de port au
prince un camp de 7000 personnes est
sorti de terre des sinistrés évacués du
coeur de la capitale
leonard doyle de l'om l'office
international des migrations qui gère le
camp un ancien journaliste irlandais est
sympa me dis sans grande conviction que
c'est un camp modèle mais modèle de quoi
oui il ya de l'eau des toilettes mais
40% des gens souffrent de malnutrition
et tous suffoque sous la chaleur bon en
plein désert c'est vraiment là d'une
question humanitaire
ceux qui disent que c'est fascinant et
on est vous avez toute espèce de famille
si vous avez des ouvriers ceux qui n'ont
jamais travaillé
vous avez des familles parents vous avez
des moyens de traces tout le monde sait
pas quand même parce qu'on voit bien que
bon là il ya eu cet espace de libérer
qui est loin du centre ville
mais il ya un problème de cadastre quand
même eu un problème de propriété
terrienne l'île appartient à un certain
nombre de gens pas beaucoup et qui ne
veulent pas partager
c'est vraiment le problème clé d'arrêter
tous les objets que veut veulent
travailler très vite pour construire les
nouveaux maison oui mais où
ou est ce qu'on met la maison une fois
avoir le titre légal avant
léonard a tenu à me présenter à son bras
l'écrivain public
cette jeune femme a perdu son mari sous
les décombres du collège où il
enseignait après quelques mois dans un
camp insalubre elle a été évacuée ici
avec son fils et sa mère
depuis elle a retrouvé une raison
d'exister les suggestions c'est les gens
qui le font
oui c'est nous c'est beau c'est non
votre souris à qui vous inscrivez qu'est
ce que vous écrivez aux organisations
aux organisations comme oyem oxame et et
les autres religions
ses toiles et les revendications
principales et leur dit quoi vous leur
demandez quoi
non je n'ai pas demandé c'est eux qui me
demandent de les aider comme de dire aux
organisations ils ont besoin de l'être
ils ont besoin d'eux
du travail ils ont besoin de de la
nourriture ils ont besoin de mieux se
loger deux mois sous cet angle là sans
bras a été l'une des premières à
bénéficier d'un relogement dans une
autre partie du camp dans des
maisonnettes censés mieux résister aux
intempéries et fournis par l'onu
l'état il s'en fout pas mal de nous
l'état n'existe pas cette terrible
ritournelle jeunesse et c'est de
l'entendre en haïti le provisoire ici
sans le définitif voilà vous êtes dans
la baie ben oui pourquoi ferait on est
là pour ouvrir les yeux et déchiré par
lou qui étaient là bas le temps du bon
du tout ce qu'elle a fait c'est le lit
de mon petit-fils et ça c'est ma vie
l'eia mélange la danse
[Applaudissements]
l'onu et les ong espèrent avoir
construit 58 mais honnête de ce type
d'ici la fin de l'année
125 milles d'ici juin prochain
sept mille personnes vivent à camp
corail
mais quarante mille personnes se sont
installées autour du camp en squattant
des terrains privés et dans l'espoir
surtout de recueillir quelques miettes
se forme est là parce que vous faites là
mais c'est tout petit tout petit par
rapport aux besoins
incroyable qu'il ya non ça doit être
désespérant mais ce que je vois c'est
que quand on fait quelque chose de bon
les espoirs mon tout petit peu les étés
arrive il est voué se croient en nous
mêmes dans leur pays parce que c'est des
années vraiment très difficile ici
[Musique]
oh
en haïti aujourd'hui rien ne tourne rond
[Musique]
le gouvernement n'est pas dépassé par la
situation il est inexistant
dix huit des dix neuf ministères du pays
ont été détruits par le séisme
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes ont perdu leur emploi
[Musique]
oh
les petits boulots sont apparus juste
pour ne pas mourir ici ce sont les
ruines du bel immeuble qui abritait la
direction générale des impôts des
papiers officiels piétiné par tous ceux
qui ont trouvé là une nouvelle ruine à
dépecer
il s'agit d'extraire du fer à béton à la
main à la masse à la scie pourquoi la
salle des fils électriques des fils
électriques
j'ai pas travail j'ai rien à manger
on travaillait beaucoup et je suis lâche
un jeu de la mer au cours de mes amis je
vais l'acheter la machine alors combien
vous vendez ça et au delà du boulot là
un dollar d'où la goutte 5 go pour 1 kg
100 kg 10 kg de cette ferraille contre 1
euro
c'est le tarif sur ce bagne ce hangar de
furnes
[Musique]
question se faire servir at il au moins
à reconstruire haïti
[Musique]
et vos cafés où vous vendez et l'avait
rejetée vous allez en faire quoi
je le revend à des gens à l'extérieur tu
veux dire en dehors de port-au-prince
non aux états unis ah c'est la plus
longue oies et aux chinois aussi mais ça
ça ne peut plus servir pour la
reconstruction d'haïti
non on ne peut rien faire avec ça
ce métal ne sera donc pas refondu ici
pour les matériaux de construction comme
pour tout le reste
le salut vient d'ailleurs de la
république dominicaine pour l'essentiel
le pays voisin
celui que la malédiction n'a pas frappé
je suis allé sur la frontière entre les
deux pays a mal face à deux heures de
port au prince
[Musique]
cette route c'est le véritable cordon
ombilical entre la république
dominicaine et haïti entre l'abondance
et la pénurie
[Musique]
une bonne partie des marchandises
vendues dans tout le sud du pays
transitent par ici
[Musique]
version caraïbes du salaire de la peur
et noria de camions des mastodontes qui
affronte de les routes défoncées
inondées ceux là sont chargés de fer à
béton tout neufs bien roulé de la
ferraille quoi comme dans les ruines de
port au prince mais celle l'abri
impeccable
à
moi je compte aller vous ça va bien mais
ici les routes sont mauvaises
vraiment très mauvaise vous venez de la
capitale de saint domingue et vous allez
où
si ça prend combien de temps trois jours
en tout qu'est-ce que vous transportez
des tiges de fer pour construire des
maisons
ouais bonne route
pas
pourquoi ces deux pays qui font pourtant
partie de la même île ont-ils eu un
destin si différents jean marie théodat
l'expliquent par le début la
colonisation
les français et les espagnols au conte
colonisé chacun à part soi une partie du
territoire
on y laisse un héritage radicalement
différent un héritage de l' esclavage et
de la grille culture de plantation en
haïti ce qui nous donne la révolution et
toutes ses suites et de l'autre ceux
qu'un étudiant à moi à paris a appelé la
tradition de l'esclave h parce que là
bas il y avait certes des esclaves mais
c'est ce qu'avaient ils surveillaient
des vaches qui étaient lâchés dans une
étendue sans limite
la tradition de latifundistes l'espagnol
ce qui fait que si l'esclavagé a existé
là bas et s'il a duré beaucoup plus
longtemps
ce n'a jamais été le régime des ateliers
des plantations que nous avions ici une
équipe du monde en marche est allé à
ouanaminthe dans le nord du pays
l'autre grand point de passage entre la
république dominicaine et haïti
[Musique]
d'un côté haïti de l'autre la république
dominicaine un pont relie les deux pays
à 6 heures du matin côté haïtien des
centaines d'hommes de femmes et
d'enfants piétinent devant le poste
frontière
[Musique]
de l'autre côté il y a le marché de
dajabon à marcher qu'à lieu deux fois
par semaine la frontière n'ouvre que
dans une heure
certains n'attendent pas l'ouverture
officielle des grilles ils veulent être
les premiers pour faire des bons d'achat
comme chez nous pour les soldes que ça
ça semble si dérisoire
[Musique]
et ici aussi les vigiles veillent
à cette heure les portes s'ouvrent
dara bonne un marché de rêve puisque
l'on y trouve de quoi faire des
provisions est ramené à sa famille le
peu qui permettra de continuer à
survivre
et à
les jours de marché il n'y a aucun
contrôle d'identité pour passer d'un
pays à l'autre
toutes ces marchandises sont produites
en république dominicaine
en quelques heures des tonnes de denrées
vont traverser le pont sans subir de
contrôles douaniers
toutes vont être chargés à bord de ces
camions qui partiront ensuite aux quatre
coins d'haïti
il y a aujourd'hui une importation
massive de produits de première
nécessité banane poulet eux aujourd'hui
sur ce que vous faites un repas en haïti
a regardé un peu dans le détail de
l'assiette vous pouvez vous rendre
compte que le même repas aurait pu être
centre de répit est repris à
santo-domingo parce que le riz il vient
parfois de là bas le concentré de tomate
le maggie les cubes qui sont utilisés
viennent la revue dominicaine le poulet
la banane et enfin la bière précédente
et que vous allez boire pour vous
rafraîchir viendra république
dominicaine ce que l'on peut voir ses
qualités devenu un ventre plat rebute
2015 un ventre l'expression est violente
et si juste
jean telus est un commerçant haïtiens un
habitué du marché de dahra bonne c'est
combien ça 200 pesos 4 euros et celui la
206 cd salami en haïti on aime beaucoup
ça se produit on ne trouve qu'ici
avec m
mais c'est combien ça 150 pesos les
commerces sont tenus par les dominicains
ils emploient parfois des haïtiens comme
manutentionnaire interprète
les uns parlent espagnol et les autres
créole ça facilite le business c'est toi
le responsable elles sont pas très
grosse des bananes
[Musique]
il est vain combien 50 pesos 1 euro je
les achète pour 50 gourdes et je les
revends 70 soit 40 centimes d'euros de
bénéfices
aujourd'hui jean telus devra se
contenter de regarder les marchandises
car il n'a plus d'argent
la semaine dernière il a vendu tout son
stock à crédit et il n'a pas encore été
payé sur le marché des haïtiens tentent
de vendre des vêtements d'occasion
ils n'ont rien d'autre à proposer
c'est triste et ça peut devenir sordide
lorsque des dominicains commence à
marchander
[Musique]
on a aussi ce type de produit en
république dominicaine
mais si on peut les trouver pour
vraiment pas cher
ils sont plus pauvres que nous car il
est très pauvre
comment vous l'expliquez je sais pas ils
vendent pourtant beaucoup de produits
ils pourraient vivre mieux
je sais pas pourquoi elle vivre comme ça
[Musique]
en fin de journée à dahra bonne les
gardes-frontière dominicain on voit les
derniers haïtien chez eux
à 16h la richesse chasse la pauvreté et
ce cas de nas
aujourd'hui haïti importe plus de la
moitié de ce qu'elle consomme
il ya 30 ans lille était autosuffisante
je n'avais pas réalisé à quel point
haïti est un pays dépendant à tous les
niveaux dépendant de l'aide
internationale
dépendant des importations dépendant
aussi de sa diaspora
ces 3 millions d'haïtiens qui ont émigré
et qui est de leurs familles l'argent
qu'ils envoient représente près du tiers
du produit intérieur brut d'haïti jean
marie théodat a vécu 30 ans en france
avant de revenir au pays
il connaît l'importance de la diaspora
pour l'économie haïtienne
ce n'est plus une diaspora c'est une
c'est une soupape c'est une partie de
l'économie c'est une partie du de la
nation je pense qu'il faut penser
maintenant réseau ce n'est plus
seulement a été ce n'est pas seulement
un territoire
haïti c'est un réseau de constituée
d'haïtiens qui vont et viennent qui
entrent et qui sortent et j'avoue que
lorsque je suis en france un peu d'haïti
que j'emporte avec moi et haïti est là
aussi
et si la terre a tremblé si fort
précisément à paris c'est parce qu'il y
avait des haïtiens ou déjà en france qui
ont un tel souci de ce pays que lorsque
la terre tremble ici ils en ressentent
secousses en france
[Musique]
superstition croyances ferveur la fois
partout à haïti les églises catholiques
les temples protestants joue à guichet
fermé et le vaudou n'est jamais bien
loin
laënnec hurbon et sociologue haïtien et
spécialiste des religions
g
j'ai vu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout va bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de loin puce moyens
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui se passe ici exactement
bon vous avez une église de dieu qui est
typique typique de la version l'a25
autistes côté son ça s'appelle un jeu ça
veut dire que ils se réunissent toute la
journée et cela ils sont la poêle vaslui
7 heures du matin pour l'application des
prières des cantiques des trois
dirigeants de défoulement c'est une
sorte de défoulement et c'est le moment
vous exprime toutes les émotions toutes
les angoisses mais tous les problèmes
qu'ils ont aussi dans la vie quotidienne
et toutes les quêtes toutes leurs
demandes toutes leurs revendications pas
cela c'est dans l'église que passerait
revendications et non pas dans l'état
auprès de l'état auquel les hommes
politiques parce qu'il n'y crois pas
parce qu'on voit bien tous les gens sont
dans les églises plus cela montre le
niveau du chômage d'iliad à lorient
[Applaudissements]
de nombreux lieux de culte ont été
détruits et quand comme ici le christ en
croix est resté droit dans ses bottes la
population crie au miracle
[Musique]
vu de lycos étaient impressionnants
depuis le sol
la cathédrale éventré de port-au-prince
coupe le souffle
[Musique]
donc toutes les religions en haïti il ya
toujours une pointe de vaudou qui surgit
un et que le vaudou si j'ai bien compris
dit que la terre c'est la mer ça veut
dire que peut-être à une malédiction
c'est clair pour la plupart des gens
qu'ils soient catholiques protestants
ouvre dix ans ils sont tous eu une
interprétation religieuse du séisme
pour eux c'est clair que ou bien il ya
quelque chose comportement quelconque
qui a été mauvais de la bad est haïtien
et qui permet que ayez cette colère
exprimée à sion c'est une couleur une
punition châtiment qui frappe haïti ses
7,7 à noter et ceux qui sont sauvées ben
c'est dieu qui lui a fait grâce est-ce
que depuis le tremblement de terre vient
de nouvelles congrégations qui sont
arrivés avec le séisme du 12 janvier
nous allons avoir un véritable défilé de
plusieurs institutions dead qui vient de
porter secours aux haïtiens et beaucoup
de groupes religieux fondamentalistes
venue des états unis en particulier se
sont installés immédiatement dans les
camps même augmenté de l'herbe et
l'église de scientologie en particulier
l'église de scientologie a plus
emblématique des sectes américaine haïti
elle semble avoir pignon sur rue laënnec
hurbon tentent depuis des mois d'entrer
en contact avec les scientologues
ce jour-là il est avec l'une de nos
équipes la porte du bâtiment est ouverte
laënnec en profite pour entrer dans la
creuse les scientologues se méfiant
générale des médias
mais aujourd'hui par chance les
consignes semblent avoir été oubliés
involontaire québécois se propose de
répondre aux questions du professeur
hurbon c'est l'occasion de comprendre ce
que les scientologues fonds tahiti vous
avez aperçu que j'ai pas eu le temps de
vous parler dans le camp de du
champ-de-mars
oui on a des canards on a le nez dans
toutes les sections de la ville va au
bouquet est ici à pétionville mais on
était à l'extérieur dans des régions
traversées comme nous les médecins
volontaires on est une division i
section de la scientologie qui
intervient après les désastres en fait
on était la première avion qui a atterri
à l'aéroport de port au prince qui avait
des médecins des infirmières
juste quelques jours après le
tremblement terre ont été la première à
avion le premier chartered qui a été
subventionné par l'association des
scientologues internationale
neuf jours après le séisme dans un pays
sans gouvernement et scientologues ont
trouvé une population en état de choc
une situation idéale pour commencer leur
évangélisation les chalets ici ils
recherchent pour des solutions pour
manier leur payer pour régler les
problèmes de leur pays
et vous vous le ramenez ces solutions on
a des solutions on a des solutions parce
que nous anciens de les gens croient que
l'esprit peut guérir l'accord et puis
plus qu'une personne est en
communication avec son crâne
plus elle peut accélérer le processus de
guérison alors on a donné beaucoup de
séminaires sur les procédés sens pour
les monétiser bien sûr et puis ça a été
très très un grand succès on avait des
gens en avait 150 200 personnes
des essais menés à des milliers de
personnes scientologue
ici c'est une secte d'ailleurs c'est une
religion enfin qui est reconnu aux états
unis par exemple en france non elle a
ajouté si je la redoute quelques pins de
la mesure premièrement c'est un problème
le fait que n'importe quel groupe
religieux soient capables de s'installer
sans qu'il y ait le moins de contrôle du
ministère des cultes de l'état s'est
envolé en tout cas de toute façon ce que
je redoute c'est cette absence d'état
cet effondrement de l'état qui peut
permettre que tout soit possible une
certaine façon les religions ont pallié
l'absence de l'état de toute façon wifi
[Musique]
absence de l'état c'est le refrain des
miséreux partout dans les campagnes les
agriculteurs qui ont moins souffert du
séisme affrontent des problèmes vieux de
dizaines d'années l'agriculture est
pourtant le seul atout du pays haïti fut
un temps le grenier des antilles
aujourd'hui elle produit moins de
denrées alimentaires qu'au xviiie siècle
et importe l'essentiel de ce qu'elle
consomme
avec la fin des grandes plantations et
la croissance démographique est venue
une déforestation massive et incontrôlée
aujourd'hui tout est à refaire et à
repenser quelques jours après le
tremblement de terre
lui aussi est de la branche humanitaire
des états unis lancent le programme
winner leur but vendre à bas prix aux
paysans haïtiens des semences pour
relancer leur agriculture
j'ai trop est un des cinquante mille
paysans qui a accepté d'utiliser les
semences vendus par winner oui je suis
chez moi alors nous avons placé au mois
d'avril et nous l'avons déjà récolté le
maïs n'est pas une culture répondu en
haïti grâce aux semences winner j'ai
trop à multiplier son rendement par
trois problèmes
les semences proposés sont en fait des
produits de la firme monsanto le leader
mondial des ogm et des semences hybrides
135 tonnes ont déjà été vendus aux
petits paysans
certains nous disent que le produit du
mou santos ne sont pas beaux jusqu'à
présent nous voulons avoir plus
d'informations concernant ces produits
là voyez un de toute façon nous les
avons utilisés parce que ces mails à ce
soit des mailles du coup de mou sans
doute ce bail là il vous en être
satisfaits bon de toute façon pour le
moment nous ne savons pas si après le
lendemain il ya encore deux applications
où grouillent des sommes qu'il ya quand
même c'est un doute concernant ces
produits là parce que beaucoup de gens
sont vraiment en utilisant les semences
hybrides
le paysan met la main dans un engrenage
sans fin chaque année il devra
réutiliser les germes monsanto éliminant
ainsi les semences locales présentes
depuis deux siècles
monsanto en distribuant ces semences
at-elle tout dit sur les limites de ces
produits les graines hybrides ont besoin
d'énormément d'eau dans les plaines le
résultat peut paraître satisfaisant mais
il en est autrement dans les montagnes
sur les hauteurs de la commune nous
rencontrons la flore ville
ce jeune paysan a lui aussi succombé au
charme de monsanto
mais le résultat ne s'est pas montré à
la hauteur de ses espérances
les produits que j'utilise ne sont pas
bons vraiment pas bon ah bon et pourquoi
vous les utilisez alors parce qu'on fait
des dépenses est on ne peut plus changer
de produit maintenant je ne suis pas
content des produits monsanto
je sens qu'ils ne sont vraiment pas
correct à la fin de ses récoltes de maïs
la flore ville a voulu faire pousser des
haricots
mais après l'utilisation des semences
hybrides ces terres sont désormais
inexploitables
s'il ne reprend pas des germes monsanto
seul capable de pousser sur ce sol
endommagé
il devra arrêter de cultiver les
responsables du s&ed et ceux du
programme winner eux n'ont pas souhaité
nous rencontrer
[Musique]
nigel fisher des nations unies crois
vraiment dans l'agriculture pour
remettre haïti en piste il m'emmène
aujourd'hui sur les montagnes qui
dominent port-au-prince ici lui sans
paysans construire une route à la force
du poignet à la force de leurs mains
pelles pioches
rien de plus dans le cadre du programme
argent contre travail ils reçoivent en
échange de leur peine 5 dollars par jour
70% en liquide le reste en nourriture
ici à haïti à partir de bendis et
bonsoir oui oui vous construisez votre
route
c'est ça qui se passe oui ça va changer
votre vie oui oui ça va changer notre
vie parce qu'on avait besoin de cette
route on en avait pas et maintenant on
pourra utiliser cette route pour aller
par qui avant si on tombait malade on
pouvait pas avoir de transport
maintenant avec la route si on veut
aller à l'hôpital ou en ville faire des
courses on pourra y aller en voiture on
est très content au moins vous savez
pourquoi vous travaillez là oui c'est ça
vous travaillez combien d'heures par
jour ici alors une heure c'était un
vétérinaire et après vous allez vous
occuper de vos champs aussi allez donc
c'est beaucoup de vous avez des champs
de quoi est ce qu cultiver les haricots
haricots cocos betteraves les petits
pois ou des tissus maïs et vous les
vendez vous le vendez acquis au marché
du porc a donc là ça sera encore plus
facile pour aller reporté les affaires
et l'idée on injecte 2 des fonds dans
l'économie locale
ainsi ça circule en même temps on ouvre
la communauté ou marcher c'est pas eu
trop volontaire personnes auraient fait
ça c'est ça une certaine manière c'est
en effet on doit prendre la porte unités
de l'intérêt du monde d'en haut en haïti
de les promesses d'investissements pour
combattre restait sur 16 et c'est pour
répondre à cette question de provoquer
pas seulement ce n'est pas de
reconstruire ce qui existait avant mais
c'est de tenter de les aider avec la
refondation du pays
ailleurs d'autres paysans tente depuis
longtemps et de manière autonome de
faire vivre la terre direction la
province de 1h au nord du pays
jean baptiste chavannes et le leader du
mouvement pour les paysans de papaye
le mpp une coopérative qui vit
exclusivement des cotisations de ses
membres son appellation est discrète
mais son impact essentiel face à la
concurrence du voisin dominicain jean
baptiste chavannes à un plan former les
jeunes paysans a relancé la biodiversité
qui fait défaut en haïti et les aider à
rentrer dans le monde moderne
[Musique]
les paysannes haïti n'ont pas accès à
l'électricité donc et dans le mpp dans
notre programme d'énergies alternatives
est l'une des composantes et la
production de panneaux solaires nous
avons un atelier pour produire des
panneaux solaires et pour permettre aux
paysans d'avoir de l'électricité avec
les techniques et qu'il a apprise laou
hep hep est il capable de mener une vie
est normale donc au lieu que les jeunes
laissent le milieu rural où aller et
environs mais pour que les gens de la
ville qui vivent dans les bidonvilles
reviennent vivre à la campagne
à la suite du tremblement de terre cinq
cent mille personnes sont revenus dans
les campagnes beaucoup sont déjà
repartis même briser le miroir aux
alouettes de la capitale fonctionne
encore
le mpp a décidé d'offrir 500 tonnes de
semences locales aux familles des
déplacés pour les convaincre de rester
peut-être nous voulons et défendre le
marché et nationales contre des produits
des ago et des entreprises
multinationales akbou toxiques et comme
monsanto
donc si on est souverain et
alimentairement eh bien on sera
certainement souvenez politiquement et
économiquement également
rendre sa pleine et entière souveraineté
haïti aujourd'hui un rêve plutôt qu'un
projet sur les murs de port-au-prince
des graffitis traite le président préval
de voleurs en regardant baisser le
drapeau devant les ruines du palais
national
comment ne pas penser à cette gangrène
de la mauvaise gouvernance et de la
corruption à la succession du dictateur
de coups d'état et d'occupation dans le
pays a été si souvent victimes
personne ici n'oubliera les duvalier le
père françois est aussi le fils
sanguinaire jean claude alias baby doc
leurs milices les fameux tontons
macoutes a fait des dizaines de milliers
de victimes
personne non plus n'oubliera à l'espoir
plus la déception
aristide plusieurs fois président du
pays avant d'être lâchés pour cause de
corruption et de trafic
des record peu enviable haïti n'en
manque pas 22 constitution 38 président
dont six seulement sont allés au bout de
leur mandat
réinventer un appareil d'état trouver
une jeune classe politique redresser les
institutions un travail de titan auquel
va se consacrer la france sous la
houlette de didier le bressan
ambassadeurs quel rôle peut jouer la
france dans la reconstruction ou plutôt
la refondation d'haïti
ça va bien désespérée si les haïtiens de
l'ambassadeur m'a donné rendez-vous à
cité soleil l'un des quartiers les plus
misérables de port au prince
vous allez essayer de recouvrir tout ça
voilà après drainé mettre des buses
moi j'avais surtout envie de savoir s'il
croyait qu'on pourrait un jour peut-être
sauver haïti de sa malédiction celle que
ce pays sera debout dans 20 ans 25 ans
moi je pense qu il faut regarder ce qui
s'est fait juste à côté un but
dominicaine ya trente ans il n'était pas
très loin de ce que vous avez
aujourd'hui extrême pauvreté
tous les problèmes du sous-développement
l'érosion une agriculture qui était qui
était complètement à l'abandon un début
d'urbanisation sauvage et en moins de 30
ans ils ont réussi à prendre le taureau
par les cornes il a fallu la continuité
politique un peu d'ordre de l'autorité
mais ça ça puisse faire parce qu'une
fois encore ça a été accompagnée par une
politique à l'état et à voile a toujours
la même chose ouais c'est ça le mode
défi majeur ici c'est pas forcément de
construire des canaux de faire des
petites des petits périmètres de
maraîchage irié de construire un canal
c'est bien sûr que tout ça aide mais le
le vrai le vrai point de départ c'est ça
c'est de remettre l'état là où devrait
malgré directeur d'école la france vient
de donner 40 millions d'euros pour
remettre les tahitiens sur pied
j'ai eu envie de demander à
l'ambassadeur si ce n'était pas faire un
chèque en blanc aux politiciens du pays
la corruption elle est pas propre à ce
pays
car dans tous les pays en développement
il ya toujours un niveau de corruption
parce que pour une raison simple je veux
dire quand vous avez été formé
dans nos écoles ou dans les écoles
haïtiennes pour devenir un bon magistrat
et que ces magistrats sont pas payés les
incitations elles sont vincent puissante
chacun doit doit s'occuper de sa famille
donc il ya un moment effectivement il ya
toujours ce risque mais c'est un risque
a dit au sous-développement il n'est pas
intrinsèque à la psychologie haïtienne
où y'a pas n'y a pas un vibrant accentué
ici depuis longtemps accentuée parce que
c'est un pays qui a une vie politique
extrêmement chaotique depuis les années
et des années n'a rien à voir avec le
séisme
absolument mais comme vous le savez de
les trois dernières années
même les 5 à 10 années on était dans des
années de sortie de crise les gangs ont
été démantelés le pays avait été
pacifiées avec l'aide de la communauté
attention puisque aujourd'hui les forces
des nations unies la minustah est
toujours là donc c'est la preuve que le
il ya encore du chemin
mais qui aurait dit ne serait-ce que au
lendemain au surlendemain du séisme
on allait tenir neuf mois plus tard les
élections dans ce pays personne les
élections elles auront justement lieu
fin novembre
la ronde des observateurs internationaux
va recommencer pour limiter la fraude
peut-être le pire serait que la violence
qui accompagne chaque élection ici
reprennent le dessus
le plus incroyable c'est qu'il y à 19
candidats à la présidence de ce champ de
ruines qu'est devenu leur pays
[Musique]
mirlande manigat est la seule femme à se
présenter des sondages d'opinion plus ou
moins fiables l'add-on favorite
c'est ma fille ça c'est moi 18 ans moi
je venais d'arriver à paris
vous avez des photos de l'époque vous
avez été première dame
voila voila et des sénateurs aussi ça
c'est mon mari résidents vous savez que
la classe politique haïtienne d'une
manière générale a quand même pas une
très bonne réputation
là vous mettez en cause aussi monsieur
je fais partie des classes va nous
parler d'une manière générale mais vous
avez parfaitement raison la classe
politique n'a jamais su organiser une
espèce de consensus
surtout pour faire face à des événements
de cette magnitude
je peux vous dire que ce l'immensité du
chantier du travail ne va pas vous
contraindre à être en permanence et
pendant longtemps sous perfusion sur la
communauté internationale et comment
mettre sous perfusion internationale
monsieur c'est une litote
sous-occupation internationale peut
explique sous tutelle internationale
je pense pour ma part que la présence de
la minustah est anormale et que la
minustah devra s'en aller mais si on
demandait le départ brusque des soldats
de la minustah
on créerait dans le pays un vide énorme
les élections qui vont avoir lieu cette
année qu'est ce qu'elles ont de
particulier
si vous voulez cette année 2010 ce matin
un certain tournant dans la vie de
l'histoire du pays nous aurons un avant
et un après 12 janvier et les gens
attendent beaucoup précisément de là
près de janvier
[Musique]
oh
fin du voyage à port au prince
2010 sera t elle l'année zéro d'haïti
l'année d'une refondation durable du
pays
[Musique]
je voulais terminer ce premier numéro du
monde en marche par une petite note
d'espoir c'est pas simple à trouver ici
en haïti
[Musique]
ce miracle c'est la rentrée scolaire
aujourd'hui vous voyez tous ces enfants
en uniforme des chaussures lustrer les
petites filles si coquette avec leurs
rubans dans les cheveux
cette image là je vous assure
quand on vient de passer quelques jours
en haïti
vous ne pouvez pas savoir à quel point
elle peut être émouvante et vient moïsi
char à lévis eh bien on va pouvoir
commencer
les très bonnes années ce temps
survint faire
je
tout ce qui est en mon pouvoir
aux audiences avouez que c'est
maintien soit clair moreau
[Musique]
de petroci tard l effort que vous devez
faire c'est premièrement dé rossi pense
que très souvent
les élèves qui pensent que telle ou
telle matière
est parfait pour lui
mais ce qui est important hamon
si vous avez déjà un esprit négatif sur
une matière où vous donne la carte sim
ont alimenté mentaux
déjà la positivité c'est important pour
que vous puissiez avoir de notre pour
cette maxime